Квантові обчислення вступили в еру практичного використання
— тобто ми вже можемо застосовувати квантові комп'ютери для розв'язання
реальних задач, зокрема тих, що є надскладними
для класичних комп'ютерів
Характерна особливість нинішньої ери —
задача спочатку розв'язується
вперше на квантовому комп'ютері,
а потім люди знаходять спосіб зробити це на класичному
комп'ютері. Цей цикл взаємного стимулювання класичних
і квантових обчислень, коли кожен підхід
підштовхує інший до меж можливого, мабуть, триватиме
ще кілька років. Існують класи задач, де квантові
обчислення можуть мати доведену перевагу
над класичними обчисленнями
за умови прогресу в таких напрямках,
як зменшення похибок і збільшення кількості доступних qubit
Є й цілі прикладні галузі,
де квантові обчислення
можуть виявитися корисними у відносно близькій перспективі
Одна з таких галузей — квантове машинне навчання, або QML
Квантове машинне навчання стосується
застосування квантових обчислень до будь-якого типу машинного
навчання. Звісно, типів машинного навчання
існує чимало.
Два особливо цікавих типи —
це навчання з учителем, коли ти
навчаєш алгоритм на розміченому наборі даних,
і навчання без учителя, при якому
алгоритм працює з нерозміченими прикладами
і намагається вивчити розподіл
або функцію, що його породжує
Алгоритм без учителя може,
наприклад, навчитися генерувати нові зразки
з того самого розподілу або визначати,
як кластеризувати зразки у групи зі схожими характеристиками
Навчання і з учителем, і без учителя часто передбачає
вкладення даних у простори вищих вимірностей
Маніпулювання даними у просторах вищих вимірностей
має одразу нагадувати нам про квантові обчислення
Поясню. Уяви, що треба розв'язати задачу: чи відносити точку даних на площині
до класу кіл
або хрестів, маючи ось ці розмічені навчальні дані
Іноді дані можна чітко розділити прямою
чи площиною у малих вимірностях
— як показано тут — і класифікувати ці точки
за принципом: вище лінії
чи нижче лінії — не складає
жодних труднощів. Але глянь на цей розподіл:
очевидно, що жодна видима лінія не розділяє ці точки
Однак для цих даних можна уявити певне
відображення з двох вимірів у три виміри
таке, що після його застосування дані виглядатимуть
ось так — і є очевидна площина, що розділяє два
класи, яку ми можемо використати
для класифікації. Якщо цей приклад здається надто спрощеним —
ти маєш рацію. Ми не можемо просто підняти потрібні точки даних
вгору без жодного обґрунтування
Має існувати відображення
з двовимірного розподілу, яке ефективно розділяє
наші точки даних, щоб ми могли
використовувати це відображення для класифікації нових точок
Детальніше це буде розглянуто в уроці про
основи машинного навчання, але досить сказати,
що задачу можна розглядати
як перебір різних відображень у цей простір вищих вимірностей
з метою знайти ті, що дають найкраще
розділення точок різних класів
Таке маніпулювання даними у вищих вимірностях
— одна з областей, де квантові обчислення
можуть справити великий вплив. Щоб зрозуміти чому,
повернімося до відмінностей між класичними
і квантовими обчисленнями. Так само,
як класичні комп'ютери оперують бітами інформації,
квантові комп'ютери використовують qubit
але для заданої кількості бітів — скажімо, чотирьох —
класичний комп'ютер може перебувати в одному з
двох у четвертому степені, тобто шістнадцяти можливих станів
Квантовий комп'ютер теж може мати шістнадцять можливих станів,
але він здатний існувати в суперпозиції всіх
шістнадцяти станів одночасно
і операції можна виконувати над усією цією суперпозицією
Для чотирьох qubit це може не виглядати
особливо вражаюче, але уяви, що можна зробити з
квантовим комп'ютером у двох у двадцятому або
двох у ста двадцяти сьомому
станах одночасно. Між класичними і квантовими обчисленнями є ще чимало інших відмінностей,
які всі відіграватимуть роль у цьому предметі
і проявляться у різних темах
Квантові стани мають комплексні амплітуди ймовірності
Маніпуляції з квантовими системами здійснюються за допомогою
унітарних операторів, і квантові комп'ютери схильні до інших
видів шумів, ніж класичні комп'ютери
Ці відмінності виникатимуть
протягом всієї твоєї роботи з квантовим машинним навчанням у сферах
кодування даних, відображення ознак і зменшення похибок
У деяких випадках ці відмінності між класичними
і квантовими комп'ютерами дозволяють нам розробляти принципово
нові алгоритми. Це був дуже короткий огляд
на перетині двох надзвичайно складних галузей,
але сподіваюся, дві речі стали зрозумілими
По-перше, машинне навчання часто розв'язує задачі,
маніпулюючи даними у дуже великій кількості вимірів
По-друге, квантові комп'ютери добре пристосовані
до маніпулювання даними у великій кількості вимірів
і роблять це інакше, ніж класичні системи
Це має дати тобі відчуття
того, чому машинне навчання є перспективною галуззю
для застосування корисних квантових обчислень